[Music]
welcome to diversity and leadership
connect with community featuring the
hispanic business student association
also known as hbsa i'm going to turn it
over to our host and moderator
who is going to be kind of leading our
session today with a group of people who
just really brighten my everyday these
are folks i am incredibly honored to
work with and watch bro while they're
here at the gsb
so with that i'm going to turn it to our
host and moderator francisco
thank you so much well you bring so much
love to everything you do and we
appreciate it
hi everyone thanks for joining us my
name is francisca
i'm uh your mba 2 moderator today
um and so today we have a panel of
hispanic identifying students
um and so i'm just going to have them go
through share their name
their year um they're where they were
before
gsb and kind of where their hometown is
uh they're tied to the hbsa the hispanic
business student association that we're
representing
and their favorite thing about the gsb
so far
so i can get this off um my name is
francisca
i'm a second year mba uh my hometown is
it's i've moved all over the place with
my parents live in guayaquil ecuador
um but i was living in vietnam before
coming to the gsb
um i am uh one of the co-presidents of
hbsa
um and proudly a member of the community
um my favorite thing about the gsb so
far uh
is obviously the cliche of the people
but just like so many people who really
care
about what they're doing and i'm going
to pass this up to
joe thank you very much francisco my
name is joe
i'm one of the um co-presidents of hpsa
as well
along with franciscan francisco who's
also here um
so i grew up in the san francisco bay
area and then i spent some time
in los angeles before coming back up
here i
am you know i'm about as worldly as
francisca she's traveled all around the
world i've traveled all around
california
so equal levels of you know
sophistication in that sense i am i'm
also a joint degree candidate
at the law school so if you have you
know specific joint degree questions i
can answer them
at least in broad terms about other
joint degree programs
my connection to the hispanic community
my mom's side of the family
is mexican they're mexican-american and
i think my favorite thing
francisco still i think it definitely is
the people gsb is my favorite thing but
just to not have the exact same answer
i'll also share that the people around
me have inspired me
to learn more about myself and grow in a
way that i didn't even wasn't even on my
radar if possible before entering
stanford
and with that i will popcorn over to
omar
sure hi everyone uh omar garza here
apologize to the audios a little bit uh
crappy
um originally from monterrey from mexico
but i moved
to the states when i started high school
so i've been in the states for a while
prior to coming to the gsb
i worked in oil and gas i'm the energy
sector
i studied uh visual engineering at texas
a
m university and um
prior to the gsb uh so it's excuse me my
favorite thing
uh being here at the gsb i think some of
everyone else a little bit of a cliche
but i mean the people have been amazing
i think there's a great sense of
community everyone that i've met has
been
um just they're very interesting
very warm and and wanting and willing to
connect with
uh with everyone else so i'm very
excited about that i'm looking forward
to spending more time here
and in case i didn't say it i'm an nba
one and we'll be graduating in
2022. uh with that i will pass it over
to francisco
hey everyone uh my name is francisco i'm
one of the
um co-presidents of the hbsa
along with my counterparts joe and
francisco
um before the gsb i worked in public
policy in texas for about six years
um and uh i guess my favorite thing
about the gsb again the people
answer is so bright but um
but one thing specifically about the
people that i really like that i always
try to bring up on these
calls is just the incredible willingness
for people to go out of their way to
help you
um and i feel like at other schools i've
always heard there's like a bit of
competitiveness in terms of full-time
recruiting or trying to find internships
um but the gsb it's quite the opposite i
have found that
especially for people who come here
looking to do a career pivot the wealth
of resources from your classmates is
incredible and people
truly do go out their way to ensure that
you are prepared for interviews that you
may have
no expertise within they help you source
companies they introduce you to people
they open their networks
so it's incredibly supportive in the
fact that um a lot of people come here
to
again change careers and and and your
classmates are incredibly helpful in
helping you do
i'll so now sorry i guess i have like
falcon's last person issa
um i'm isabel i was born and raised in
quito
so i'm an international student that's
where my family is at um
my connection to hvsa is that this is a
community that
i hold near and dear to my heart and
that has been a source of a lot of
support for me
um favorite thing about the gsb
i was gonna say the people and the trees
because the trees here are also
so beautiful um but i'm gonna
do a deeper dive into the people um just
i live with four
other gsbrs and the conversations over
dinner
are where i've learned and grown the
most
um and i think i answered all the
questions
you did thank you so much um so these
are our panelists today
uh for those of you who are trickling in
uh we're a group of nba one
and twos um who are all in some way part
of the hispanic business student
association
and so really quickly uh the hbsa as we
call it
um is a student identity organization
so we put on different kinds of events
to bring the community together
we also do kind of like advocacy for
getting more hispanic students
into the gsb um we also host
an annual alumni banquet honoring a
distinguished hispanic
alumni um last year we celebrated billy
alvarado who's
the cf cfo of stripe um and so that's a
really nice way of bringing in alumni
and current students together
and yeah generally we just try to foster
kind of a sense of community
so uh today what we thought we would do
on this panel is
first uh kick it off with some
misconceptions that we commonly hear
commonly hear from students about the
gsb so we'll do this for about 10
minutes
and then we'll bounce over to you all
for any kind of questions we're here to
be honest and open so
get your questions ready and we're
excited to answer them
so i guess um just to start i know
there's a lot of different things that
are out there about the gsb
on the forums on different things um i'd
love to kick it off over to esa
to talk a little bit about the
misconception around academics at the
gsp that we've commonly heard
yeah i had a conversation with joe about
this actually and i really like the
phrase he used that
um the gsb is kind of a choose your own
adventure kind of uh
scenario and um the adventure that i've
chosen is one of like
prioritizing academics um i'm a
non-traditional student i was working as
a teacher before coming to the gsb i
studied
philosophy like i really want to learn
finance and accounting and operations
like these are
the skills that i didn't learn in the
workplace i didn't learn
in my undergrad um so this is what i'm
prioritizing in my time here and getting
the most out of stellar faculty
um for other of my peers um they've
learned a lot of the skills that we're
learning in class already in their
workplace and
maybe they are prioritizing a very
vibrant social life
or um really the professional side of
things
so um i'd say that that's a
misconception that i want to break is
that people don't care about academics
here
thank you issa um i think the second
misconception we want to talk about was
a kind of like
this maybe elitist culture that it seems
like gsp gives off where it's hard to
connect
to people during the application process
or beyond and i wanted omar to
talk a little bit about this
sure thing um that's a great question so
i think
the admissions team has done a fantastic
job recently kind of
demystifying the process of what it what
goes into the
uh the emissions process and and getting
admittance into the gsb that being said
you know whenever you look at the class
statistics that's over there's
roughly 90 u.s institutions uh
of higher ed plus give or take another
50 from
around the world that um of people
that's
studied at these institutions that come
here so i think
in the end of the day it's about why
why why are you a good fit here rather
more than
just being hey you have this very like
elite profile and this is why you should
be
getting accepted into the gsb i think in
the end of the day what
what matters most is who you are what
are you bringing to the table
and and being a decent fit um that being
said i think
as far as who to reach out to and things
like that you know
most most gsbr's are always um um
open and welcoming to to speaking with
people i think
uh in the end of the day what's
important there is is to have a
a good reason why you want to connect
with that specific person
and to come prepared as well right i
mean they're also taking time out of
their schedules to to chat with you
uh so in that sense you want to make
sure you come prepared and and you know
why that that specific person someone
you want to talk to
thank you omar um and along the same
lines
uh frank i was wondering if you could
talk a little bit more about
uh what it takes to get into the gsp and
kind of misconceptions around that
yeah yeah yeah i think that um
you know now having been here for a year
and a half or so um
i do think that people develop this this
idea and i guess that the
acceptance rate probably exacerbates
this a little bit but develop this idea
to be like some incredible superstar to
get in here
and i actually find that's not the case
of course everyone here is incredibly
impressive and incredibly smart and
engaging
um but what i think really um
what i think really uh defines the
people here um
more so than the fact that they you know
start a billion dollar company
which most people have not is their
one i think ability to engage in
meaningful self-reflection to the point
that they understand their weaknesses
and their faults as well as their
strengths
and that that self-reflection comes
through in their applications
and two that they've just done very well
and are able to articulate
what they've been able to do and
sometimes ordinary jobs and so
you know if you come from kind of you
know pretty standard background for
instance
um even if you feel like oh i don't have
the right name brand whatever
there are tons of people who come from a
broad broad
kind of diverse backgrounds from a ton
of different companies many of whom
i think may not fit the traditional gsb
mold
but for whom they are able to articulate
again kind of how they've shined within
their job how they've made
change or value within the companies
that they've worked organizations in
which they've worked
i mean people on this call for instance
as a teacher i worked in public policy i
mean
there's just not there's just not a
standard fair student um
and in terms of the essay i think that
the thing that when i talk to folks
about their applications that i try to
stress most is just
of course you want to toot your own horn
to some degree you want to trumpet your
accomplishments but
i would say as importantly if not more
importantly is is
is um is that you should be able to
again articulate how the gsb
fits into your personal growth and part
of that comes from also
recognizing again where the gaps are in
your personal growth and so
if you feel like you need to improve
your manageable aptitude image your
aptitude along any number of lines
articulate how that's the case how the
gsb fits into that mold
and i think that kirsten moss and the
other mission staff like to see that
their
their applicants are reflective they're
vulnerable
they think about themselves and their
accomplishments and they have a kind of
a reasonably articulated path for the
future
and how the gsb fits into that path
i love that more talking about like the
journey that you're on rather than like
you being a finished product
um thanks frank i think the last
misconception
at least i hear a lot is um the what
matters most usa and i know will lead
a panel on the essay
piece but i think like a lot of times
like it's kind of this crazy
thing that you have to write maybe make
people cry like
have it be this kind of emotional thing
um and i'd love for
each of the panels to kind of go through
and talk about kind of what they wrote
about in their essay and
and you know what they think about about
how any advice they would give on
writing that one
um i think i can kick this off and just
say that
i i think being honest and genuine and
true to yourself as you write it even
though that seems really
hard i think it's kind of like what what
is in your gut like what what does your
gut tell you to write
um and for me that was really touching
on
inequality so i grew up moving around
latin america and the us
and i was like very fortunate in how i
grew up and so i talked a lot about how
that perspective has shaped kind of the
work that i've done
in international development since then
and it felt like i read it i read it
yesterday in preparation for this and i
felt like it was still
true uh to me um a year later and i
think that's a good
good marker for for how you might write
it
i'll pass it over to um omar if you
could share
a little bit about your essay and just
kind of any advice you have about that
sure thing so my essay of what matters
uh or what mattered and what still
matters most to me
is about living a balanced life
um i went ahead and talked about these
five
principles that i live my life by which
include
family friends faith
fitness and then finance which is kind
of like your job right your professional
life
and i talked about how i balance all of
these uh
throughout my life and like why that
matters to me um
so again in the end of the day i don't
think anyone's
read this and thought this is the most
touching thing i've ever
read and started crying and you know
published it and and sent it to a ton of
people but i think it was genuine and it
was like this is who i
am and this is like and this is how the
gsb also like fits that mold and why uh
i'm interested in coming here so i think
my advice there again
similar to what i think everyone else is
going to say and
touch on is just to be honest and be
yourself
um i'll pass it over to joe this time
you were the popcorn e now you're the
popcorn or back and forth between us
omar
um so yeah i guess my first thought on
the um
the essay is like i sort of
contextualize it when i work with i went
to ucla for undergrad go bruins if
there's any
ucla people here and i do a lot of work
with undergrads and when you're thinking
about
the essay as part of like an mba
application i generally like to think of
it as part of you know like you have
years of you know professional academic
personal growth and experience
that you've done you have you know years
of you know other types of things that
are being part of so the s is just one
part
of your overall application so i think
it's really important to contextualize
that to not sort of you know over index
on that to the extent that you know sort
of causes other considerations there
um but to answer the question
specifically what i wrote for my essay
i wrote about really being involved you
know i had a career before in finance
and working with startups
and i wrote about how i really wanted to
start a business that was you know a
little bit
more um sort of like social impact
oriented as opposed to just specifically
being sort of a for-profit entity so you
could think of it from an econ
standpoint of having sort of
positive externalities in in the world
and i
am you know feel really fortunate that's
sort of what i'm spending a lot of my
time doing right now
with different startups and i think the
gsb helped me get there so it was
it reflected back on the essay and i was
like oh you know joe a few years back
writing was says i would be really happy
with you know sort of where i am right
now and how gsb has helped me get there
and i guess on that note i will pop corn
over to issa
my essay was on
lifting people's stories as a way to
bring about social change
so i wrote about helping high school
students write their common app essays
and tell their life story in that way
a dance i did with dining service staff
in college
um so nothing like
game changing or like large in a
particular sense but i think it really
captured my values
um and the advice that i give high
school students when i help them apply
and write coming up essays for college
is
to just like lean into the
reflectiveness
that this opportunity um to apply to
schools gives you
um and and to like even if things don't
work out the way you're expecting
just um the act of telling your life
story and reflecting on what matters
most to you
is really valuable and it's something
that i try to do
once every couple of years
francisco um yes
i get i wrote my essay so i co-founded
the organization that i worked for prior
to coming here
and i wrote myself a couple of things i
talked about kind of how i saw
public policy and politics as a
one of if not in my opinion the most
important framework by which you can
kind of change people's
lives in a meaningful generational way
and then the second
was how i wasn't a very good manager um
like i had staff and i don't think i was
a particularly good boss and i talked a
little bit about like
how i came to that conclusion and how i
you know was going through a period of
growth and
and um you know kristen moss like she
writes if you know once
once you're accepted she gets she writes
you a little handwritten note on your
on your um application i said she and
she
um on your screen and your acceptance
letter and she referenced that and like
you know talked about how
she hoped that the gsp could provide
kind of the framework for growth that i
was looking for so
um that's just why i continue to stress
the idea that i think that they're
looking for
some some self-reflection in your essays
and and and
that you don't have to be this like
perfect package when you're applying and
you should be open about that
thank you so much everyone for sharing
um
as you can see a wide range of things
um but all kind of very introspective
and looking at kind of
deeper values and and like how people
see the world
um we'll transition over to questions
now
and feel free to i know will is
answering a few more like tactical
questions
in the q a box uh feel free to send any
kind of questions
and we're really here to talk about the
student experience and anything that you
have around there
but i guess i'll start us off with um
a question for anyone on the panel is
uh could you guys describe what the
community the gsb latino the tnags
community is like
it's a group that is very diverse um
you have people that are like me
international students that grew up in
latin america
you have people that are first
generation second generation children of
immigrants
um and it's also
very lively in different ways like some
people like organizing large events and
lots of dancing
and other people are more like
franciscan which is small dinners and
board games
um i think something that i'm i'm hoping
that i can contribute my grain of sand
uh is to increase the number of latinos
that are children of immigrants and that
actually don't have a live story like
mine um i think that
there might be an over-representation of
latinos that went to
private schools that taught them english
from a very young age and that
um were prepared for perhaps not
stanford business
school but at these good schools and i
think that there
could be more diversity in terms of the
stories um
just more of a presentation is always
better um but that's
um how i would describe this community
yeah i think that that just i think
that's exactly right i think that
to um to to kind of articulate a point
that isa made was that
um i think that we try to be a big tent
and um
you know recognizing that um
that it you know being latino i mean
latinos are not a monolith as we uh
everyone talking about from from from
the election of course and
um that uh there is an opportunity to
you know create community out of
sometimes very different cultures and
backgrounds
um so i think that we do i mean try to
be as inclusive as possible i think that
um you know even folks that are just
have an interest in latin america
or or in latino culture i think we try
to engage as much as possible so
you know it's a supportive community i
think it's a close-knit one and um
yeah we're all we're all friends yes
uh just mba wants perspective really
quickly
um so going to the gsb at the very
beginning of the quarter
um you go through something called the
academic adjustment period where
uh no club can reach out to you you
can't do any recruiting etc just so you
can adjust obviously to
to being a student again but quickly
after that ended i mean we
you know we had um people from the
community reaching out to me directly
into a federal nba ones and
i i think that speaks volumes to how um
how they want to kind of um just like
propagate this culture
of inclusive of inclusivity and just of
of
having some sort of just building these
warm relationships out
uh so again only been here for a few
months right
and just getting started but even in
that short
amount of time i'm already feeling that
sense of community
thank you omar um
awesome uh so we have a few questions
coming in from the audience
um i'll take uh
daniel serrano's uh question and maybe
uh joe and frank could help with this
um can you share a little bit more about
the programming hvsa puts on
are there any types of career support in
addition to providing community
yeah i'll go um first on that and then
i'm sure frank will have
things to add i think that it's a you
know in these
extraordinary unprecedented times it's
um you know difficult sometimes to think
about sort of what the community looks
like during
covet i can say you know we've been very
intentional um this year about you know
sort of setting
zoom events you know socially distant
outdoor you know sort of
those types of activities actually are
sort of disallowed right now by stanford
so the extent to which people are sort
of comfortable
meeting casually comfortably in a way
that everyone feels safe is okay but
it's been
somewhat difficult with the sort of
current um
virus situation to do a lot of you know
sort of very
um serious programming historically in
the past we've had such things as sort
of a um
a weekend retreat off site wherever at
least for me that was a huge part of
really feeling like the bonding
in the relationship and really feeling
like hpsa was sort of like my home and
community of people was spending the
weekend
the others i love that and as i think
franciscan mentioned earlier
we normally do um sort of like an hbsa
dinner
and gala type event where we have a
speaker come in so there's a lot of and
then normally throughout the year
there's such things as you know an
initiative we're starting this year
something called the hbsa familias which
is a concept of a group of you know sort
of like
mba twos and mba ones working together
to sort of say okay hey how can the nba
2 support the nba ones
academically professionally emotionally
during the the process because we've
lived through it
and then you know also just sort of
additionally building community
now to answer the other question about
professional resources i think that
that's
um there are a lot of um professional
resources available i think there's you
know some of it's sort of a little bit
more ad hoc the nba ones asking mba twos
you know specific questions you'll see a
lot of that throughout stanford as i
can't remember who had mentioned this
point earlier this idea of you know you
can really just reach out to anybody
in your class or who's currently at gsb
and if they've worked at a job or worked
with someone who you'd like to talk to
they're going to you know go out of
their way to make sure you can do that
and so the same is true with hbsa
students
then there are you know additional hpsa
specific resources company will reach
out to the
cmc the career management center and say
hey we're looking specifically to hire
you know insert group and sometimes
that's someone you know from a lot in
background
and then those will come directly to us
through hpsa so there's some specific
job opportunities that sense
so high level i think there's a lot
happening both with the sort of you know
interpersonal community standpoint and
from the professional standpoint
things are a little bit different this
year maybe because of kovid
but um overall that's you know very
robust focus on sort of building
community both from you know sort of a
friend's standpoint and from a career
thanks joe anything to add frank
no i think that that that joe pretty
much summed up but yeah we have
we have banquets we have parties we have
events we have
small get-togethers obviously coming to
change things a little bit um
but i still think that i at least try to
do um
you know one-on-one meetups with with
nba ones as much as i can
um so it's yeah it's it's it's ad hoc
and in terms of the career resources
you know i think that one thing that
that is an incredible boon here
is that um i think that the latino alums
are incredibly responsive and this is
it's across the board actually i mean
every ever i have never had an alum not
respond to a message
from me um they may not give you
everything that you want but
uh they will always answer the email and
i think the latino alums are especially
diligent in doing that as well
awesome i can share an example of how
the community can support each other uh
with jobs
so i really wanted to learn more about
sesame workshop because i really like
sesame street and i wanted to work
in that over the summer and then
francisco's wife
like her cousin is nina latina like the
character
so then just introduced me to her and
that was like
really insightful and that's the kind of
like connections that
really drive the world forward um and
i'm very happy to have this community to
help me out
when i want to work for sesame street
amazing thank you everyone um
i'll just take a quick second to answer
a question from d
ries about working with companies or
governments in latin america whether
through hvsa or otherwise so
there's actually a career like focus
uh group called uh los a latin american
student association that really focuses
on bringing in
um people from latin america and kind of
fostering and facilitating connections
there gsb has
a crazy amount of alumni across latin
america
i think they actually just hosted a
panel on philanthropy and
i think vc on monday from
like really prominent latin american
people and so
um there's a lot there's a lot going on
there
um okay uh another question that came
from
rodolfo was can you talk about the
interactions with professors and alumni
outside the classroom
i can go so both of them have been
extremely
positive um and i would say almost
like surprisingly um just people have
been
surprisingly like receptive and
responsive so
i am trying to i'll start off with uh
reaching out to alumni so i've been
trying to pivot into an industry that
uh i don't have experience in and that
being said i've started doing some
networking and started reaching out to
people and it's been
just ex just extremely
positive results so far every single
time i reach out to someone they
they respond um and i've already had a
few phone calls and even during these
covet times when
you know people might you know might not
know what's going on with you know their
firm or what's going on in the industry
they still want to talk to you they
still want to help you out
and that's something that's reflected uh
really well in on the gsb community and
the alumni community so i'm pretty sure
everyone else can speak to that but at
least it's been my experience in the
short two months that i've been here
that it's been very positive and i look
forward to continuing that on
uh and then as far as professors go you
know that's a really good question
especially
i i came from a large public university
uh where i just walked into class i sat
down
i took notes sometimes and then i just
you know went back
uh went back to my house and i would
study or whatever right
uh in here it's just it's very different
you know you're an adult now and you're
treated as such
and having said that a lot of these
professors they're they're willing and
wanting to talk to you they even set up
little like office hours outside of um
outside of class for you to go talk to
them and they have amazing experience
like some of these professors have
founded companies so they've already
done things that you want to do and
they're
very willing and wanting to speak with
you um
so that being said it's it's amazing
it's just it's very different from what
i've done in the past
and from what i've seen in the past and
i'm very much looking forward to just uh
to like forming these relationships with
professors going forward yeah
my favorite hbsa alumni story i totally
forgot her name but
um she i think she was like president of
hbsa when she was at stanford and she
created this like
racial justice alumni get together over
the summer
when the black lives matter movement was
top of mind for everybody
and it was just such an incredible thing
that was very organic
and there were these breakout rooms and
you'd meet alumni and there were alumni
from all identity groups but it was
um led by this particular woman and and
just that sense of like we're here to
learn from each other and to support
each other as we try to
lead positive change in our communities
and in
this range of workplaces was very
encouraging to me
in terms of faculty
something that i was not expecting was
with this transition to zoom
classes some professors wanted to run
pilots and test
if their classes were going well or not
and um
that's just so cool like there's this
professor called deborah gruenfeld who i
think is
incredible and um she wanted students to
help her see if the class was running
well or not so i like signed up for all
the pilots
and that level of like getting to see
like
the creator of power and social
psychology
like one-on-one several times and give
her feedback on what's working
um is very unique to small schools
um yeah and one more thing on the
faculty side is
you know the the professors and the
lecturers here
they really are resources and i think
they that the reason why they come back
here and spend
you know their extremely valuable time
i'm sure a very low hourly rate teaching
us is because they want to give back to
the school
and um you know as an example i came to
school wanting to try real estate so i
took the real estate class in the winter
it's a big real estate class it's
offered it's kind of a hallmark of the
gsp if you want to if you're interested
in real estate
and the two professors or the two
lecturers um our guy
our guys name chris chris muhold whose
son is in our class
and then a guy named doug abby doug abby
i mean they both have founded
massive massive real estate investment
funds and doug gabby is one of the
founders of prologis which
is like pulling up the ticker here it's
a 75 billion dollar
uh reit and i
like i email them quite literally all
the time and every single time
they every single time i email them they
get back to me within like 25 minutes
it's actually astounding i don't know
how they respond so quickly they're also
yeah
especially given their age um and uh
anyway sale of that because as i was
considering kind of opportunities for
the summer
in the real estate space i would
constantly kind of volley ideas at them
and they would always provide feedback
for me as to like do they know the firm
do they know the people
could they do some vetting for me um and
now in the process of doing something
like startup garage uh
in which we're working the real estate
space they have been eager eager
participants in our interviews we sit
them down for sometimes hours at a time
and ask them questions and they will
always answer and introduce us to more
people
so again they kind of the lecturers and
professors here kind of
offer back what you asked of them but
they're extremely helpful if you go to
your way
amazing um thanks everyone for sharing
uh definitely like a wide range of of
interactions there
um so there's a couple questions from
marichui
and the first was uh your biggest fear
coming to gsb and how you faced it um
the second one i think was interrelated
or potentially is like
uh as a latinano latina how welcome do
you feel in class
classes or programs like do you feel out
of place
at all um and anyone can
answer i'll hop in um
so my i think a big fear i had coming to
gsb so when i started i was a little bit
on the younger end and so i think there
was some sort of like um
concerns about not necessarily being
included in social things from a social
standpoint because of age you know what
i
found was really nice about gsb is like
i think everyone just sort of thinks of
each other whether you're one of you
know the youngest students or one of the
oldest
students in the class everyone just
thinks of each other as peers so for me
the sort of age concern i had was you
know
evaporated even before i started at some
of the admitted students
event so that was really really nice for
me and i um
i definitely enjoyed that and the
francisco was the second part of like we
as hispanic students feel
comfortable and welcomed in the
community yeah exactly um
definitely i don't think i've ever
experienced anything other than people
feeling you know really interested in
mind and i think i have a you know
perspective of someone who's you know
my name joseph walters oftentimes people
don't know that i um you know identify
as latino or know anything about
my mom's side of the family unless i
bring it up and it's normally something
that people are very interested in and
would like to learn more about and
i think it you know as a conversation
starter more than anything else so those
are yeah those are the fear and then the
welcomeness um i can jump in and answer
really quick um
so this wasn't my personal experience
but i've definitely heard from a few
like latina friends
who have said that they've experienced
some kind of microaggressions
um on campus and i just want to point
this out because i think it happens
anywhere it definitely happens at the
gsb
um and it's i think particularly with
the murder of george floyd this summer i
think there
there has been a lot of conversation
around black lives matter and also just
generally about
um underrepresented minorities at the
gsb and how
we can um kind of decrease the burden
that people face at the gsp and also get
more people
into the gsb i know there's a question
from charlie yates on
um the gsb action plan and like how much
that's actually working to get more like
staff and student and faculty that's
more diverse into the gsb
and i think it's still kind of early
days for that um but i
just want to flag like there's there are
issues i think people do experience
things
um the gsp's culture is like uniquely
focused on
feedback and so i think like a lot of
times people do like have these
conversations but
um i'll open up to the panel in case
anyone else has thoughts on that
i can i'll echo a lot of what both joe
and
francisco have said so having just
gotten here
the majority of the time i mean if not
the entire time i felt like it's been a
very inclusive environment where
everyone is mostly
interested in finding out more about you
like everyone's so excited to meet one
another it's like
oh my gosh you're hispanic amazing tell
me more about it like that every time
you're so and so like can i please hear
more about it
uh so so for me and my time here it's
been
um it's been nothing but positive and
inclusive
one of the things that i will say about
francisca francisco's comment
is i have heard from a few other people
um
comments of hey i've experienced a
microaggression here or there
one of the the things that i think is
important to note
is that a lot of time that comes from a
place of
ignorance right it's it's not
necessarily in any way that they're
trying to hurt you or anything like that
it's just they they don't know better um
and to the point of the gsb culture
focusing a lot on
um on feedback and and constructive
feedback i mean
in vulnerability i think it's a it's a
great place for you
to give that put yourself in a
vulnerable position and let them know
give them the feedback hey by the way
when you said so and so you know it made
me feel this way and then
i promise you everyone will auto correct
after that
so those are some of the key points i
wanted to to touch on
thank you an area that i've been
thinking of
particularly around my role is what
happens when it's international
at latinos that say microaggressions
towards
first and second gen like latinos um
because i like that i've seen it where
there's comments like oh even you're not
really laughing when you don't speak
spanish
and it's just a lack of acknowledgement
of the diversity that is within our
community
um and maybe ways in which i can speak
up a little bit more and try to share
more
that there are very different stories
and not speaking spanish does not
invalidate your identity as a latino
heck brazil doesn't speak spanish and
it's
more than half of latin america um
it is definitely something that um i see
as an area where we can grow as a
community
thank you issa um i'll take it to a more
a broader question from diego flores how
has the gsp
experience influenced your point of view
on what to do after your mba
i can come in a little bit um let's hear
it i like i really like the question
around what's your fear
um so i'm gonna touch into it a little
bit i think one of my fears was that i
was gonna be like a cultural anomaly
because i'd heard all these stories
about business school and it sounded
like
a dangerous place for someone who was
like
a social justice warrior in college
and and that was definitely not the case
i i found community
but i think it also helped me um it
challenged
some of the stereotypes that i held
about business
and and expanded my understanding of
what are professional paths
and it exposed me to stories of people
that
are doing really good work within
companies
within the private sector and also um
the fact that life is long i guess i i'm
also on the younger side joe
and i think especially like
in my younger years just this idealism
of wanting to make change right now
and then realizing that a lot of the
people that have made really impactful
change sometimes
um go through more traditional
established paths and
learn a lot like i think
i've started to think of consulting as a
potential path for me and that was not
something that i had ever even
considered or
um understood well um so i think that's
how
it's expanded my understanding of
professional paths
one other um note i'll just emphasize i
think everything is said was
spot on and one thing that was really
interesting for me is i feel like
you know you learn a lot from the
professors who are here but you also
learn
so much from your um classmates and
colleagues in terms of
you know careers they've had you know
roles that they've had companies they've
worked out that might not have even been
on your radar
and sort of that whole path has been
really um valuable for me
and understanding of okay these are
people who've you know been and you know
insert
job at insert company and insert sector
and that you know gives you a lot of
information then you get you know really
candid responses it's one of your
friends maybe you're just talking over
dinner
and a lot of it you know you're just
interested in the person and you're
learning a lot about them and it's fun
you're building a relationship
then after you know you reflect on it a
little bit you're like oh wow i learned
so much
about you know a specific job a specific
role specific company
so that's something that's been um
really really interesting for me and i
would sort of call like you know just
like
learning through osmosis from being
around a bunch of you know really smart
energetic
motivated people who are willing to
share their stories with you
i love that joe yeah i definitely have
learned a lot and i can answer really
quickly
i kind of came into the gsb being like i
want to focus on emerging market tech um
and then when i got here i went to every
single
like background lunch which is like when
companies come in during lunch time and
they tell you
i went to a million different things i
was really interested in
autonomous vehicles i was really
interested in kind of
different technology and different like
approaches i thought about going to the
non-profit sector
and then now i'm like back into like
focusing on emerging market tech
um because that's kind of like what the
path i was on
and i really got to explore and i got to
see different things
i also had a lot of time with the career
coaches where they were like
listen you're not really into consulting
and they kind of like played stuff back
to me
um so you know everybody's journey is
different and maybe you
show up like and end up somewhere
completely different or maybe you just
end up exactly on the path
that you're on but it's there's a lot of
like resources along the way
um let's see okay so there's a question
uh about um entrepreneurship
so any can you mention any resources
that gsb
including the student body community
provide to support entrepreneurial
ventures
um there is a lot so maybe uh anyone in
the audience who
are in the panel who has like specific
experience with some of those
yeah i can i yeah there's stanford i
think really prizes but the gsb
and the university really prides itself
on
graduating a lot of entrepreneurs both
immediately after graduation and after
the fact
so not only are there a litany of
classes that provides
uh that provide overviews and kind of
deep dives into everything from
vc to kind of uh
to to startup operations to
you know the ins and outs of kind of a
term sheet to
um you know how to hire and how to kind
of organize a sales force on an original
hr team
everything all the above um there's also
kind of
quasi practical classes that you can
take ranging from lean launch pad which
is kind of the lean model of a startup
um and then their startup garage which
i'm in this
this quarter that in which is kind of um
it's supposed to be like a design
thinking focused course
on starting a business in which you
start with a lot of interviews and then
move into you know business prototype
and design
uh you can also and the important thing
to note that i didn't really
know before i came here was there's you
can as a gsb student you can take
classes across the street we call it
across the street which means that
you can take classes at basically any
department within the broader university
and so if you want to learn how to
you know build a video game you can take
video video game design
in the in the computer science
department um if you want to take
classes of design school to help kind of
focus your vision and your design
thinking process you can take
classes design school you can take
classes wherever you want to if you're
interested in energy and alternative
vehicles you can take classes in
engineering you can do all kinds of
stuff
so not only is there just a strong
thread of entrepreneurship among
your classmates many of whom kind of
come here with visions of starting a
business either immediately after
graduation or sometime in the future
but also i think the school really goes
out of its way to
give you the resources to hopefully be
successful the other thing that i'm
forgetting is venture studio
there's a there's something called the
stanford adventure studio which provides
a ton of resources financial and
otherwise to help get your business off
the ground
gives you office hours with vcs with
lawyers with accountants with anyone you
could
you can imagine so there's quite a few
resources
i also mentioned i'm on the presidency
the entrepreneur club so like we also
have a club
francisco's the president of like 12
million clubs so
isa no i was just going to say netflix
yeah i think for those of you there's a
lot of people who come in like knowing
they want to do entrepreneurship i
wasn't sure and i got funding this
summer to like try out
uh idea that i had around older adults
and technology
and so i think like if you're
entrepreneurship curious it's definitely
a good place for that too
um cool uh so there is some talk about
uh
dual degrees uh joe specifically can you
talk about and i don't have anyone else
i think isa is also doing a dual degree
and i don't know about frank um
uh talk about your experience doing a
dual degree and they said like
application class workload anything like
that managing your time
sure and not to get too technical on you
i'll put my law hat on for a second
there's a difference between those joint
degrees and then there are dual degrees
so those
in and of themselves there's many um
variations there francis but some of
them so you can do um i think
gsb does a really good job frankly of
integrating across um different
departments and also across different
schools
so there's quite a few people in our
class who are you know doing a joint
degree with
for example harvard kennedy school which
is the school of public policy
over at harvard people doing programs at
the woodrow wilson school over at
princeton and there are a lot of those
types of things as well so you don't
necessarily need to be all stanford
i'm admittedly biased and i chose to do
my joint degree with the stanford law
school as opposed to a different law
school
but um i've really enjoyed it i think
that you know because
every program at stanford is on the
quarter system it's pretty easy to
integrate
your um you know joint degree or dual
degree classes and so that's been
something that's been really nice i mean
for example this quarter i'm in
law school classes and gsb classes now
admittedly if it weren't um coveted i'd
probably have to be maybe running back
and forth between the schools a little
bit now i just sort of
close one zoom window and open a
different zoom window so it actually
makes it pretty easy
for me um at least for this quarter um
i feel very supported by gsb there's you
know they have sort of they call us mba
pluses
which means that we're an mba plus some
other sort of degree and they have
specific academic advisors
for us related to making sure that you
know not just that we're on track with
everything related to gsb
but we're on track with everything
related to these other joint degree
programs so i often have found that my
um
advisor at gsb knows more about what i
need to do for the law school than
sometimes my law school advisor does
so that's been really nice and i do feel
very very supported
at gsb with the joint degree that i'm
doing and that's everything from
academics to career to you know personal
stuff and there's also you know sort of
clubs for joint degree students and i
also just will randomly tack on here
because i saw in the questions there was
a question about sort of integration
with different um you know latin
groups across um stanford and i know
there you know there are similar groups
so i'm involved in there's the
stanford latinx law students association
our acronym is salsa which i've always
loved
and um we um you know like last year and
two years ago we've done events with
salsa
and there's other groups you know with
the med school and those sorts of things
i think there's a lot of you know
professional school
um you know relationship building as
well so those are my
high level thoughts
i'm a dual degree with the education
school here at stanford 2.
um there's around 30 of us we call each
other mamba
um and i think
it's been an awesome way to meet people
that
are quite different from the business
school students um
like it's a very different community
with very different interests
and it's helped me kind of grow um
just who i interact with especially the
community of 30 dual degrees
we did like a hike um two weekends ago
and it's been
um a great source of support as as we
tend to share an interest in a sector
that
isn't always as profitable as the more
traditional business
school sectors
thanks isa thanks joe um great to get a
lot of different perspectives so
i know we have a lot of questions in the
chat and it's going to be tough to get
to them so we'll take one more
uh from uh marichui again on
on financing your mba program so if
anyone has any thoughts there
um because i know that's top of mind for
a lot of people uh
for all of those other people with
questions that we haven't answered
uh we'll post our like general hbsa
email that you can reach out to
we can provide more tactical answers
there um but yeah does anyone have any
thoughts on marijui and then we'll
transition to the close
so i just laughed a little bit when you
brought that up francisco because i try
to actively avoid
my i'm thinking about my um student loan
debt that i'm incurring
while i'm here i think that there's a
large percentage of
people at gsb you know some people are
fortunate and have financial resources
to you know not do that i'm not one of
them i you know
have a lot of you know debt that's
involved here i think that um
what is nice about gsps there's a lot of
you know really smart
academic business oriented people we're
gonna help you figure out the best
possible resources to get the best
possible deals on your loans there's
entire
slack channels we have dedicated to
people who are on financial aid and
where you're getting loans from and the
best deals
and collaborations and those sorts of
things you can do so you're definitely
going to get
you know some of the best insights and
financial resources but at the end of
the day your
tuition bill is going to hit you and
you're going to have to you know pay for
it one way or another
so um that does exist i would just say
as someone who
you know basically had a pretty large
you know potential
amount of debt to take on to come here
you know you can fund that in a few
different ways in addition i mean
stanford's financial aid office is you
know very
um i think they do a very good job of
understanding your specific situation
and saying okay what are the resources
you have available how much can we help
you
related to that and um you know so some
of that will be funded
oftentimes if you don't have um you know
financial resources something that will
be provided by stanford
some of it is loans but you also there's
you know during the summer you're going
to be commanding sort of an
mba salary during the summer so it's you
know for a lot of people substantially
more
on sort of you know a weekly or monthly
basis than they're making before and
then afterwards you're going to have a
you know post mba job that is going to
helpfully so i think that there's while
there are sort of like financial
considerations sort of taken together i
think that it was you know much more of
a
you know sort of better financial
investment than i was sort of even
expecting it to be
when i'm looking at it where i am now
versus where i um had originally started
coming in
i i would also add to um just be on the
lookout for scholarships as well
um the hispanic scholarship fund they
they can they give out scholarships
um lunacap foundation those are
for either uh former military or
uh mexican-american uh and then there's
like the
i think paul soros scholarship and
that's for first generation americans as
well
um those are three that i can just think
of off the top of my head there's
probably many more out there but just uh
obviously
financing the mba is important and just
be on the lookout for for other
scholarship opportunities
awesome thanks omar thanks joe um
we'll just wrap it up here thank you so
much to everyone for attending um i'm
gonna ask the panel for
kind of rapid fire words of wisdom for
our attendees
and i put our the email you can reach
out to i'm not promising an immediate
reply but
we'll try to get to you as soon as
possible um
anyways uh words of wisdom and thank you
again for attending
um and i'll pass it to francisco
um yeah i just i've said it a thousand
times but um
you know don't feel like you need to
like blow the socks off of admissions
i think that if you can just articulate
some some
um some
some of your accomplishments even if
your job um
doesn't seem like the most outstanding
job in the world just accomplishments
that you've made how you've made an
impact
how you hope to make an impact in the
future and then some self-reflection
about
how you hope to grow as a person and
what the gsb can provide for you
oh right uh issa go
um my words of wisdom would be what
school you end up going to
does not determine your self-worth
i'll pass it to oman
um so words of wisdom as far as
application process
goes just reflect and put together
um the most compelling story about who
you
are um and i think that's
that'll that'll get you where you need
to be
sorry i'll pass it over to joe thanks
for that omar um
yeah i guess uh specifically on the
application process my one
big piece of advice is the extent to
which there are you know people who know
you
well that you can you know ask them and
get sort of feedback from a lot of
people i know sometimes there's a sort
of tendency to get a lot in your own
head
about the application process i know
that was true for me so whether it's
like thinking out ideas out loud with
people
you know having people review your
resume whatever type things i think that
getting other people
who you you know know love and trust in
the the process that's going to be one
supportive for you and two is going to
ultimately probably have you
come out with the best work product
i love all this advice and i i would add
that um
think of this as a life check-in for
yourself so whether or not you
actually end up attending business
school figure out if you're on the right
track to where your goals are you don't
need
maybe you need business school maybe you
don't um it's a good time for
life reflection and something really
valuable you can get out of it
regardless of like what acceptance
letters come in
at the end of the day anyways um thank
you so much our panelists
for their time and thank you all for uh
your curiosity and your interest
and we hope to hear from you um take
care
and stay safe out there and with that
thank you so much for attending this
session we hope to see you throughout
the week
thank you to our panelists and thank you
to all of our attendees
go out there stay safe be inspired and
hope to see you soon